botox soll der nächste nicht nur in der
schönheitschirurgie eingesetzt werden
sondern auch bei ganz anderen
beschwerden mehr zu einer neuen
behandlungsmethode jetzt bei klick zum
science fiction das nervengift
botulinumtoxin kurz botox wird schon
seit mehreren jahren in der promi welt
geliebt lippen aufspritzen falten
ausradieren und so weiter kosten für
vier monate stürmten rund 120 euro im
jahr kosten falten also ungefähr 360
euro also sie zu entfernen je nachdem
wie viel gemacht werden soll was viele
nicht wissen botox wird tatsächlich auf
jeden anderen medizinischen schienen
angewendet und nicht nur zum aufhübschen
von gesichtspartien oder ähnlichen
botulinumtoxin setzt den muskeltonus
herab die aktivität der muskeln nimmt
also ab diese lähmenden eigenschaft wird
in vielen fällen von starken chronischen
schmerzen und krämpfen übermäßigen
schwitzen und bei zähneknirschen benutzt
um den betroffenen zu helfen
diese physischen beschwerden werden
schon mehrere jahre lang derartig
behandelt doch was haben solche
physischen beschwerden mit der psyche zu
tun
wenn wir trauer oder schmerzempfinden
sieht man uns das schnell an besonders
an unserer mimik ist das zu sehen die
augen senken sich die mundwinkel fallen
herab und auf unserer stirn bilden sich
nach und nach fallen im mittelpunkt
einer botox therapie gegen depression
steht der musculus kurator super cdi das
ist der muskel der für unsere falten
über den augen zuständig ist wenn ihr
eure stirn runzelt dann arbeitet genau
dieser muskeln wenn jemand an einer
depression erkrankt ist kommt dieser
muskel kaum zur ruhe
und damit wären wir auch schon beim
botox das nervengift beeinflusst ja die
muskelaktivität und das mit psychischen
erkrankungen auch oft unkontrollierte
muskelkontraktionen einhergehen ist
bekannt doch welchen einfluss soll dann
der stirn muskel auf unsere psyche haben
eine studie des gerontopsychiater smart
axel wolter von der asklepios klinik
nord in hamburg und sein kollege
tillmann krüger beschäftigt sich mit der
wirkung von botox auf die psyche des
menschen
vor drei jahren führten sie an 30
patienten die erste placebokontrollierte
studie durch 50 der erkrankten
teilnehmer bekamen wie der name der
studie sagt ein placebo das heißt nicht
den wirklichen wirkstoff den 150 prozent
wurde das echte botox gespritzt nach
vier monaten konnten die mediziner nicht
nur gestraffte gesichter sehen sondern
auch eine deutliche veränderung der
stimmung bei dem patienten über die
hälfte der patienten die mit echtem
botox behandelt wurden ging es deutlich
besser marc axel wollner zur folge hat
unser gesicht nicht nur die fähigkeit
gefühle auszudrücken
durch die fatale feedback schleife könne
mimik gefühle intensivieren
durch die botox-behandlung wird die
funktionalität dieser schleife
geschwächt die placebo gruppe konnte
ähnliche verbesserungen spüren jedoch
wirklich langanhaltend war der placebo
effekt nicht sobald die teilnehmer
merkten dass sie mit einem placebo
therapiert wurden würde das
gegensätzliche konsequenzen mit sich
bringen
der placebo-effekt wird zu einem low t
ball effekt viele der mit placebo
behandelten werden sich dadurch in ihrer
depressiven stimmung bestätigt fühlen
in unserem gehirn gibt es jede menge
spezialisierte bereiche einer der vielen
bereiche ist für die bedrückenden
gefühle zuständig genannt wird dieser
bereich amidala während unter den
genannten 30 probanden nur leicht bis
mittleren repressions fälle behandelt
wurden untersuchten die experten die
wirkung des botox auch an gesunden
menschen resultat amidala zeigt eine
deutlich verminderte aktivität
die studie ist spannend auch weil wir
ständig auf der suche nach neuen
behandlungsmethoden sind so der
psychiatrie chef an der berliner
schlosspark klinik tom gsoa
er gilt auch als spezialist für
depressionen die sich schlecht
beziehungsweise kaum mit den vorhandenen
therapieverfahren behandeln lassen
bis zum heutigen tag wurden insgesamt
drei derartige studien durchgeführt zu
wenig um die therapie als akzeptiert
bezeichnen zu können bevor die methode
mit botox in serie geht müssen noch viel
mehr erkenntnisse gesammelt werden alle
drei studien beschäftigen sich mit
leichten bis mittleren fällen von
depressionen doch was es mit den
schweren fällen
wir können noch nicht von einer
etablierten therapie sprechen
dafür braucht es größere studien und
noch mehr erfahrung sowohl man wie
schwer das leben mit einer depression
ist und noch mehr über das leben des
ehemaligen profi fußballer sebastian
deisler könnt ihr euch in dem wirklich
packenden hörbuch sebastian deisler
zurück ins leben anhören wenn euch das
leben eines profifußballers interessiert
dann kommt er hier oben zu unserem link
zum hörbuch da könnt ihr euch dann einen
pro account bei audible erstellen und
bekommt sebastian deisler zurück ins
leben vollkommen kostenlos als geschenkt
unseren link findet ihr natürlich auch
unten selbstverständlich in der video
beschreibung wie immer wie alle anderen
links jetzt gleich eine große rolle bei
psychischen erkrankungen spielt
natürlich mobbing es kann ziemlich viel
anrichten und mehr zu den folgen auf
unseren gesundheitszustand und ob
mobbing sich auch noch schlimmer auf uns
auswirkt als misshandlungen erfahrt ihr
im video hier oben und zur app und zum
block kommt ihr hier unten zack und
würdet ihr euch für wissenschaftliche
studien ein nervengift wie das botox
spritzen lassen
habt ihr vielleicht schon mal an einer
studie teilgenommen schreibt es uns in
die kommentare ich bin gespannt bis dann
bleibt dran